So you,
so you went from being an intern to working with lupine and then being an
in-betweener to just going straight into the dragon ball. Super. No, no, no,
of course not.
So Mike had done my internship at telecom animation theme satellite.
So I have done two internship, uh, six months, uh, if you.
Put it all.
Together. And, uh, when I finished my school, I said, okay,
I have it in two internship. Uh, I know it's hard. That's a take on me.
It was a good mood at a, at a Saturday.
I just was more cold and you have to hurry and you are,
you are paid or so by frame. So the, the money.
Yeah.
It's per frame here rather than per day to ask you what that might be out of
frame.
Uh, well, when you're in between, uh, you are paid,
they're like a two euros per frame.
Two euros per frame. Yeah. That's Holy.
Seven USD. So you would draw a fruit, go to family, Mark,
get a sandwich and you just
play three or four bucks us less that's before tax, right?
Uh, yeah. Oh,
I assume you wouldn't even make enough to go for the tax cost.
When you take a drink. You okay. Uh,
can I bought by maybe? Yes. Oh, I have to do.
So. So your, so your you're making a good choice.
I need to draw more so I can eat. Okay. So how,
how long would you say it takes you to do a frame?
I guess it depends. Depends. The frame can be just five minutes, right? Right.
Uh, some frame can do cute. Two, three hours.
That's. I mean, this has been a hot button topic in the industry for a while.
I think, I think a lot of people do talk about the animators get paid,
but just hearing it from natural animator, just, you know.
And also because nowadays the anime getting more details and
more, more lines.
How's the scanner more soccer.
It was 50 years ago. Uh, when you draw one frame,
you can eat one ramen. Right.
But the rate of the life increase, but the frame.
Yeah. Oh, okay. So now you have new inflation. So now if you want to.
Um, and you hear that at least to do a five or six frame. Oh, Mark.
If you don't mind me asking, when did your internship initially,
how much are you getting paid for that? And w were you living off Justin.
At the first internship? I wasn't paid. Oh, wow. Yeah. Okay.
But the second internship.
I was paid, so it really was like a passion.
It was a patience thing.
Then I was knowing that my internship you are paid or not, but they,
I was paid. So by, by frame for my internship that Saturday. And so I knew,
okay, it's really hard. So I tried to do my best, but yeah,
I always, or just my one month, my best recorder, when I wasn't your internship,
it was just 150 hundred. The frames.
Yeah. Solely Twitter. So like $300. Yeah. Oh my gosh. For a month, for a month.
And a specialized a job as well.
So this wasn't my internship. And so it wasn't.
So wait,
the guy who was probably cleaning the toilets at the studio was probably getting
paid more than that.
Yeah. Honestly, it's probably true. If you walk a company.
Put it into perspective, like not trying to diminish any jobs of cliquey,
but like, I mean, you know, cleaning the toilet is not a specialized skill.
McDonald's especially considering how art school was like one of the most
expensive school. I was trying to little, any of the jobs, we need those jobs,
but like yeah. The fact that it is a specialized job. Yeah.
You can do your best was 300.
It was my internship. I had an.
Internship. That's not enough to live. Right. And.
Yes, sure. But, uh, like I said, I, um, my mother dripping, yes, I am fair.
I had a family in Japan, in Tokyo, so, uh, yes. Uh, yeah,
it was cool because my family, I was living in the house of my, uh, grandmother.
So it was okay.
Oh, okay. That's nice. That's like rant or anything like that.
I was, I had luck, but if I, so I was thinking Manny for foreign people,
if you don't have family. Yeah.
Did you have friends who didn't have family here? Who.
Yeah. But, uh, that today get a bitter.
They could negotiate a better than me. So that's why you'll have to,
uh, now the good advice is you have to look, uh,
the good statue to, uh, take a lot of information of each Sergio.
Did they pay? Yeah. I'd say it was, uh, yeah, it was just the entire him.
So I cannot take exemplar status,
but I more example on graph Nika [inaudible] was doing in
between the digital in-betweens. Right, right, right. Digital.
It was more quicker.
Okay. But that was the pay. The same.
The pay was the same, but the pay was the same, but, uh, we had a [inaudible],
uh,  it's mean, uh,  so you have a, or a fixer amount of salary and it was, uh,
at least, uh, uh,  400 euros a month, a month. And you end date ask you to do,
uh,  300 frames per month. It was at
least do 300 frames, at least 300 frames a month. And so when your
success to do the [inaudible]
you to your source 300 to two years,
you have 600 plus this fixed salary.
[inaudible].
For a specialist job. It's still quite low.
Very low, but.
Uh, my best recourse, wet, uh, recalled. Well, uh,
when I was doing in between, uh, uh, 600
frames a month. So she's gonna go to the tour.
[inaudible] 502.
For an internship. That's probably like $1,500. That's probably not bad.
Okay. Well, let me most wailing space over there.
And he's like sweating right now.
Yes. And so most of my coworkers and I have I'm working, um,
I'm living with, uh, at my parent's house.
I'm living with a share house. It must have. Yes.
So you have to pay attention about your money, how you spend,
it's not a glamorous lifestyle. I don't know. You, you, you,
you don't leave your survival, right? Yeah.
I think a lot of people, sometimes don't like,
I remember I've had people come too. Cause I'll be like with like, uh,
I remember I had a animatics player. I was with trigger and they were like, Oh,
they want a job at trigger. And I'm like, do you do,
do you really want a job where like,
you really have to work your off or you work hours? Like if you don't.
I do a Griffin ago. Yeah.
So I started at 10 and, uh,
and it depends on about the deadlines or you have some time I arrived and
there is a lot of kids and my senpai. Oh,
you have to finish this for this evening. Yeah. At eight. Okay.
I will do so. I don't eat lunch.
Blonde shirt. Very opposite. It was a little bit.
Yeah. And sometimes they have, Oh, some good kids. I want to do this.
Please let me do this. Okay. Just wait. I need three days. Oh, okay.
Well, what I would say, because I wanted to as Pokemon guys,
so I wanted to walk Pokemon, uh, and.
You make an exception and you're like, I like Pokemon. I ruined my life,
which was brew, uh.
Blue. Yeah. It was a Pokemon generation on YouTube.
Oh, cool. Wow. Yeah.
Yeah. And it was blue with a I in Japanese. You say CMX summit. I don't know.
In English. And so there's French.
Names as well. Isn't there? French localized.
French names, Tatanka.
[Inaudible] I learned about that.
Apparently the French lift stations were like really well done for Pokemon
really, really well done.
And all the names were like really well thought out and stupid,
like a mix of Japanese and French mythologies. I mean, Tom, Tom,
Tom sounds bad. He's a tank. That's awesome.
Wow. That is like the very opposite of European lifestyle where it's like, Oh,
it's five. Oh, the building's on fire. It's five. O'clock I'm going.
It's like this.
So yeah. Yeah. In between you have to be passionate. You have to love.
And you mentioned that a lot and also it depends what kind of experience you
want if it's just, Oh, I want to walk.
I just want for this show or narrow two on one piece. I don't know. Or,
Oh, I was just a one who, two years experience in Japan. No,
I wanted to have a carrier in Japan, so.
Right. It depends on what they experienced.
So you often find people come into the companies.
Like I only want to be here for a year or two then go back. Yeah.
Yeah. So sometimes you have,
sometimes some people have came in Japan and they had some homesick because
it was the first time they came in Japan and the food didn't go well
and they couldn't speak Japanese. So yeah. So it's the most,
an English was a so-so. Yeah. So yeah,
so he was difficult to make some friends. And so yes.
You still have a hanger around, we did the same people. So.
Just a couple of completely different lifestyles.
Did you know English before you came to Japan?
Yeah. Well, I was leaning, learning English at school,
so yeah.